Ja, die Leute assoziieren mit Stefan Tietze geschmackvolle Anekdote.
Wo kommt es Hot jetzt her?
Äh, mich.
Hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot, hot.
Schade, dass du dich so wenig fortpflanzt.
Bumsen-mässig in der Gegend rumvögeln.
Du bist wieder im Flirt-Mode.
I'm a little lawbreaker.
Durch meine Grösse alleine schon bin ich der, an die angeschmied wird.
Bei 1,97.
Eine fantastische Liebesgeschichte.
Und dann kommt die Flughafenszene.
Je t'aime Burble-Up.
So klasse romantisch. Da wird einfach da wird geballert, ja. Boah, Stefan, weißt du, wie peinlich mir das ist, so was? Du hast das Intro ausgewählt, ich weiss nicht, warum du weißt du, wie unangenehm berührt dich jetzt gerade? Ich sitze hier mit hochrotem Kopf. Ja, eine riesen Erektion. Ich will dich so nicht kennenlernen. Du kennst mich auch schon.
Aber ich will nicht diese Art, diese Lovemaker, diese Flirtmaschine, diese Sexmaschine Stephan T. Du hast jetzt gerade zehn Minuten nach dem Intro gesucht, das ausgewählt, es ist vorbei und du sagst, ich bin so hochrot berührt jetzt. Ja, weil uns die Intros ausgehen. Ich bin ehrlich, es herrscht Intro. Armut, das soll aber jetzt überhaupt gar nicht wegnehmen von dem fantastischen Intro von Käthe, das uns eingeschickt wurde. Vielen, vielen Dank an Käthe, die hier vielleicht auch zu persönlichen Zwecken mal ein Hot-Off Stefan Tietze gemacht hat. Also in diesem Hot-Off ist, wie ich Je Tem sage, das reicht dann schon. Manchmal reicht das schon. Französisch ist eine heiße Sprache, kann man schon mal sagen. Sehr lippisch. Wie läuft es eigentlich bei dir in Französisch? Schlecht, schlecht, schlecht, aber die Franzosen haben sehr schöne, viel mit Lippen, bewegen sehr viel die Lippen. Deswegen glaube ich, ist es auch so etwas laszives, voluminöses, mit schmatzenden Lippen, feuchtschmatzenden Lippen, die aneinander reiben, was man ja in Frankreich quasi an jedem Gelato-Stand so erleben kann. Wohingegen deutsch wenig feucht schmerzende Lippen, die aneinander reiben. Überhaupt nicht, ganz trockene Lippen, purös. Sondern eher die Zunge, die Akrobatik. Boah, das ist so viel los. Die Zunge muss so viel leisten beim Deutschen, dieses Harte. Ja, ja, genau, das ist sehr hart. Bei mir tatsächlich auch Abnutzungserscheinungen, ich zerfalle. Meine rechte Hand ist rau. Meine, meine rechte Hand ist rau und die linke nicht. Und die ist so aufporöst und ich überlege jetzt wirklich, ich bin einmal durch meinen kompletten Alltag gegangen und habe überlegt, wo entsteht, also du kennst ja, wenn du irgendwie vom Auto hast, an einer Seite irgendwie Schmutz und am anderen nicht, dann denkst du dir, was ist da los, wo kommt der alte Karren hier, was ist da und dann merkst du du, ah, die eine Brücke, wo, ne, so, ne, so, ein Sherlock-Moment. Was machst du nur mit der rechten Hand? Genau. Ja, so, und jetzt habe ich natürlich, weil ich bin Fahrradfahrer, Fahrradfahrer, bring, bring, und dann dachte ich, okay, gibt es da irgendwelche Windkanalsituationen, wo sozusagen die kalte, harte Luft nur an einer reibt und so. Weil du schon mit 400 Kilimitern über die Fennoer-Strasse bretterst. Das mag ich am Fahrradfahren, dass du nicht weisst, wie schnell du bist. Im Auto bist du immer so, okay, ich bin gerade schnell, Alter, ich bin richtig schnell. Beim Fahrrad zieht du einfach so ein achtjähriges Mädchen an dir vorbei, oder du ziehst selber an irgendjemandem vorbei. Und das ist alles, was du hast. Du hast beim Fahrradfahren nur die Verhältnisse.
Ich glaube auch, also ich hatte mal früher einen Tacho fürs Fahrrad, deswegen weise ich, wie schnell man fährt.
Warum klippst du dir denn an den Lenker?
Naja, weil manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich möchte gerne die Rätsel lösen. Mir brennen die Fragen wie dir auf der Zunge, ich würde es dann gerne wissen und dann löse ich die Probleme durch Käues tacho was nach was nach zwei weiss nicht akkulaufzeiten nicht mehr funktioniert und da habe ich gemerkt man fährt so als kind damals bin ich so 20 kmh gefahren ich glaube man kann sogar schneller fahren ich kann bis zu 30 kmh fahren mit meinem oder vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr mit meinem rennrad und das ist lustig weil freunde aus einer anderen stadt haben beobachter dass in köln wird langsamer fachrad gef. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das in Holland glaube ich auch, wo es sehr flach ist, haben Leute dann auch eher sozusagen so diese Lowrider-Holland-Fahrräder, wo man nicht so schnell fährt, sondern eher so ein gemächliches Tempo hat. Kann natürlich auch mit besseren Arbeitsbedingungen oder whatever zu tun haben. Man muss nicht um Punkt neun mit der Arbeit sein. Erwartung, ja, na klar, dem kapitalistischen System, das da dem Zusammenfall inbegriffen ist. Aber es ist natürlich auch interessant. Ich finde es lustig, dass ich Städte einigen auf Fahrradtempi. Ja, klar, weil natürlich, wie gesagt, du merkst ja nur, oh, ich bin schneller als der, ich bin langsamer als die. Gemessen an der Stadt, in der du wohnst. Genau, und wenn alle einfach insgesamt langsamer werden, dann fühlen sich alle gleich schnell, aber es wird einfach langsamer. Ja, das habe ich ja schon mal vorgeschlagen, bei den Olympischen Spielen oder sowas, immer höher, schneller, weiter, brauche ich nicht. Denn wenn alle, auch bei der Formel 1, da wird ja auch was verschossen an Kerosie oder sowas, da wird das ja, das ist ja der absolute Oberknüller, was da alles rausgehauen wird. Wenn wir uns alle entscheiden, alle, alle zehn Prozent runterzugehen, ist es ja immer noch genauso spannend. Absolut, ja. Wir merken den Unterschied nicht. Die Kameras können eh nicht einfangen, ob die jetzt 300 oder 4000 kmh fahren. Es sieht für uns Fernsehzuschauer eh immer gleich aus, wenn wir alle jetzt einfach 80 Prozent von dem geben, was wir eh können. Ja, finde ich gut. Können die alle freitags frei machen, alle, können die ganzen Ingenieure von McLaren sagen, okay, weißt du, freitags ist für die Familie gedacht, und trotzdem gucken wir noch genau das gleiche spannende Rennen. Also familiäre Werte, Umweltschutz verbindest du hier ganz elegant in der Formel-1-Revolution oder halt auch so ein Zebrastreifen. Oder einfach so, um es damals spannender zu machen, dass man einfach noch so ein kleines Hindernis hat, wo man dann warten muss oder sowas. Hürde, ne Hürde. Ja, wo man dann drüber springen muss. Habe ich letztens ein tolles Video gesehen zum Thema Hürdenlauf, wo es, also was mich fasziniert hat beim Thema Hürdenlauf, man muss nicht über die Hürden springen. Also die sind da, aber du darfst auch deine Linien nicht verlassen, right? Man darf die Linien nicht verlassen, genau, du darfst nicht außenrum, man darf nicht um die Hürde. Das hört sich auch runden drunter, es gibt nur zwei Varianten. Aber du kannst generell sie umhauen, umtreten, du kannst sie wegtreten. Und tatsächlich gab es früher, als Sportarten noch nicht so durchreguliert waren, dann irgendwann einen, der gesagt hat, ich trete die alle um. Aber mit so wütenden Augenbrauen die ganze Zeit schon losgelaufen. Haut auch noch nach dem Rennen noch so auf die Hürden raus. Und der Trainer muss ihn so zurückhalten. Jerry, Jerry, Jerry, du hast gewonnen, du hast Gold, okay, du hast Gold. Ich hasse Hürden. Mir geht es nicht um Gold. Ich hasse Hürden. Und der ist einfach durchgeballert, bis sie irgendwann gesagt haben, Leute, das ist nicht der Sinn der Sache. Mittlerweile gibt es ein komplexes Regelsystem, natürlich wie immer, wie komplex kann es sein, bei fucking Höhenlau. Wo genau steht, einerseits wie die Hürden gebaut sein müssen, weil natürlich die, wie leicht die umfallen, ist natürlich eine Sache, weil wenn die schwer umfallen, dann ist es eine grössere Hürde. Also es sind schon Hürden, aber es soll keine so grosse Hürde sein. Und tolles Video, gebt einfach mal ein, hurdle me, hurdle me this. Ist Sache auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es sehr spannend, weil an irgendeinem Punkt ist ja wie sozusagen, du studierst Medizin, an irgendeinem Punkt musst du dich spezialisieren. Du weißt schon, was du machst grob, dann guckst du, was macht dir am meisten Spaß, und du gehst in diese Richtung. Und das gibt es ja bei Athleten auch. Zum Beispiel bei, du kannst sehr schnell rennen oder sehr schnell sehr lange rennen, also Richtung Ausdauer oder sowas. Und an irgendeinem Punkt trennen sich ja die, die einfach nur schnell im Kreis laufen und die Hürdenläuferinnen. Heißt, wie bescheuert, sorry, muss man sein, um sich für den Hürdenlauf zu entscheiden? Ah, weil es ist exakt das gleiche, nur mit fucking Hürden im Weg, über die nur springen muss. Und vor allem, man würde ja denken, dass das schwieriger ist, über Hürden zu rennen und deswegen auch, dass der prestigeträchtigere Sport sein müsste. Nein, wir alle kennen Usain Bolt, den besten, schnellsten Mann der Welt. Wie heißt der schnellste Hürdenläufer? Weiss man ihm, weiß niemand.
Kennt niemand, kennt niemand.
Und deswegen ist es ja eigentlich komisch, weil ja der leichtere Sport populärer ist und man denkt,
hä, da sind Hürden drin, da sind irgendwie noch giftige Schlangen auf der Strecke.
Ich meine, wir alle kennen die Sportart Giftige Schlangen auf der Strecke, aber Snake Run.
Giftige Schlangen im Weg, Snake Run.
Der deutsche Titel ist Ferrig.
Aber niemand kennt den aktuellen Goldmedaillenhalter. Niemand, obwohl es der schwierigere Sportart ist. Hallo, wir sind wieder zurück aus der Werbung. Mein Name ist Tom, gegebenenfalls ist für mir Frank. Wir freuen uns wieder, Sie begrüßen zu dürfen. Hallo Tom. So Schlangen liegen im Weg und wir haben heute ein fantastisches Rennen vor uns, nicht wahr? Es wird ganz fantastisch. Renate Obelhuber ist heute mit dabei auf der Eins. Sie hat schon vorhin gesagt, dass sie ein gutes Gefühl hat und die Schlangen tatsächlich, wir haben ein bisschen Ostwind, die Schlangen werden auch ein kleines bisschen nach Westen gedrängt, also eher auf die Außenbahn, da steht Vanessa Wambel. Da steht Vanessa Wambel, die deutsche Medaillenhoffnung, denn hier können wir uns wirklich was ausmalen heute, Bronze ist drin, vielleicht sogar Silberfrank? Ja, auf jeden Fall, die Französin Jeannette Schmarais ist natürlich auch angetreten, um zu gewinnen heute.
Tatsächlich. Und was die Linien angeht, hat sie eigentlich eine ganz gute Bahn. Die Schlangen sind eher, wie gesagt, eher alle bei Vanessa Schmee. Richtig, vom Ostwind getrieben, denn das macht Sitzschlangen besonders zu. Wind. Schlangen bieten eine grosse Angriffssäche. Für Wind wissen viele nicht, sie werden Richtung Osten gewählt. Hier sieht man eine Flangenschlange, wie sie ins Publikum gewählt wird. Warum ist der Wind? Okay, aber du weisst, du kennst dich damit Schlangen aus, ich bin nur der Laufexperte. Absolut, oh und ich sehe, da geht es gleich los, der Ringrichter kommt heran mit der grossen Pistole und alle stehen bereit und jetzt geht es los. Drei, zwei, eins. Daumen drücken, Frau Wambel. Knall, da geht's los, die alle spriten los. Da geht's los und die Schlangen wehen.
Sie wehen alle zu Wambel, Wambel, sie hat vier Schlangen am Schienbein, sie geht zugrunde,
das Gift, das Gift, das Gift wirkt, oh nein.
Das war's mit Wambel, aber die Französin, sie ist ganz vorne und sie ist stark und
sie hat einen guten Lauf erwischt.
Und sie läuft und sie trifft keine einzige Schlange und sie ist im Ziel, sie ist im Ziel Schade, Schwamm, sie ist im Ziel. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Weltrekord. Alle Schlangen stürzen sich auf Vanessa Wambel, leider. Schade, aber naja. Ist es nicht, vielleicht sollten wir mehr Regularien haben. Eine Schlange pro Linie oder so. Und ich brauche keine Schlangen und Hürden. Ja, nee. Das ist ja da, wo wir unsrannt. Weil manche Schlangen klettern die Hürde hoch. Und da habe ich die Größe zu sagen, das war ein Fehler. Wirklich? Obwohl du so dafür gekämpft hast. Immer wenn ich einen Fehler zugebe, stelle ich vorne weg. Und da habe ich jetzt aber die Größe auch zu sagen. Und wenn du halt einen Fehler zugibst, ist es eine coole Eigenschaft, weil Leute freuen sich. Und Leute halten dich auch für einen moralisch integrieren, wenn nicht sogar überlegend Kerl, wenn du sagst, sorry, da habe ich mich verrannt, ne. Neulich habe ich behauptet, wir würden vor der Ruine des Stadtarchivs in Köln stehen, das ist immer eingestürzt. Und dann war die lange nach der Museen und irgendwie waren wir in so einer großen Stadtruine. Du hast eine Privatführung gegeben. Nee, und ich habe dann so gesagt, da waren stadtfremde Leute, hier war das Stadtarchiv und dann war ein anderer Kölner, der meinte, nein, das ist das nicht, die bauen hier einen. Moment, aber da will ich den auch nochmal in Kritik nehmen. Wenn jemand öffnet, in der Gruppe, ich nehme es an, war eine Gruppe von Leuten, wenn jemand irgendwas behauptet, was nicht stimmt, dann sagt man nicht öffentlich, nee, das stimmt nicht, dann redet man danach mal privat miteinander. Aber das macht man nicht, das finde ich, das geht nicht. Ja, naja, es war einfach grobe Bullshit, den ich gesagt habe. Ja, aber es war Bullshit, der niemandem wehtut. So, und dann hätte ich sagen können, sorry, tut mir leid, ja, du hast völlig recht, ich habe mich da jetzt vertan. Habe aber gesagt, ja, da habe ich jetzt auch die Grösse, dazu zu geben. Und es ist so lustig, wie es alles wieder wettmacht. Und alle hassen dich noch mehr. Und es ist sofort so, ach sofort so alle alle hassen alle alle routen wieder gegen dich ja da bin ich mir jetzt auch nicht so schade zuzugeben ich bin jemand der auch fehler zugibt wo kommt ja so politik oder so wahrscheinlich aber ich finde das so uncool diese diese als rhetorische kniff verkaufte Arschloch-Move den alle sofort auch hassen niemand. Niemand wird danach, ah ja, er hat die moralische Grösse, niemand applaudiert dir, wenn du sagst, da habe ich jetzt die moralische Grösse zu sein. Richtig, du darfst dir nicht zu sehr selbst applaudieren, da bin ich jetzt auch Demokrat genug, um zu sagen, nee, da haben wir was falsch gemacht. Ja, okay, und es ist ... Weißt du, wer Antidemokraten betont, dass sie Demokraten sind, das würde ich nämlich sagen. Das würde ich nämlich sagen. Was muss das für ein wilder Tag gewesen sein, als Stefan Tietze meinte, ah hier war ja früher das Stadtarchiv von Köln. Es war die Lange Nacht der Museen. Mag ich immer sehr gerne und ist mal wieder so ein Beweis, dass in Köln dann doch zu wenig passiert, weil es ist einmal die Lange Nacht der Museen, da haben bis drei Uhr nachts oder so alle Museen auf, überall sind kleine Veranstaltungen, Musik-Acts und so, ich finde das immer natürlich toll, aber ganz Köln macht das dann, gerne.
und ich finde schön, dass so gut angenommen wird, aber es ist einfach unenträglich, du stehst bei jedem Museum draussen irgendwie eine halbe Stunde im Regen, bis du reinkommst und dann ist da in der Garderobe nochmal eine lange Schlange und das ist einfach, weil es passiert einmal im Jahr was in Köln, neben Karneval. Und alle stürzen sich drauf. Mach das doch einfach viermal im Jahr. Ja, oder wir brauchen mehr Museen. Oder noch mehr Museen. Also wenn die Schlangen lang sind, dann brauchen wir mehr Museen. Es gibt ja immer noch neue Themen. Museum ist ja ein extrem kreatives Feld. Es sagt ja niemand, hier sind ihre zwölf Museen, suchen sich eins aus. Wenn du jetzt Franchise, also du willst jetzt sagen, komm, ich erfülle meinen Traum, ich mache jetzt mein Museum auf. So wie bei Fast Food hast du Subway, McDonalds, Burger King, bei Museen unendliche Möglichkeiten. Ah, du meinst, wir sollten Museen verfranchisen? Ja, Schritt zwei vielleicht, aber finde ich erstmal eine gute Idee, einfach mal zu sagen, dieses römisch-germanische Museum hier auf der Donblogue. Wir machen zwei draus. Wir machen zwei draus. Das römische Museum und das germanische Museum. Warum das diese paar Vermengungen? Ja, die kommen sich eh mal in die Quere und die Fans stehen sich gegenüber in Schildwall-Formationen. Das funktioniert so nicht für mich. Doch kein modernes Kunstmuseum. Macht ein modernes Museum und ein Kunstmuseum. Oder man geht den anderen Weg und man nimmt zwei sagen wir mal eher mittelinteressante Themen und führt sie zusammen. Ja, das Bleistift- und Arbeitssicherheitsmuseum oder das Bleistift- und Wikinger-Museum so zusammengeführt. So, du hast eine, du hast ein bisschen Wikingerzeug. In Köln gibt es das Senfmuseum. Genau. Das Bleistift und das Senfmuseum, finde ich so schlecht. So, finde ich nicht schlecht. Du hast immer so ein bisschen Senf und dann, ah, jetzt könnte ich aber auch wieder einen Bleistift vertragen. Und dann viel Spaß an den Kuratoren oder die Kuratorin, die das so langsam in Richtung Bleistift lenken muss. Oh, gibt es eine Doppelspitze? Gibt es einen Senfkurator und eine Bleistiftkuratorin und dann kämpfen die immer so, wer jetzt das neue Exponat kriegt. Oh, wir haben einen neuen Raum, wir haben noch einen Raum gefunden. Hey, hinter der Tür war die ganze Zeit noch ein Raum. Super, würde ich einfach dann ausschmücken mit Senf. Dankeschön, Marianne. Ne, Moment mal, aber wir haben ja eigentlich, weil wir aktuell noch die Hälfte der Fläche haben bei Bleistift und Senf, dann hättest du jetzt... Ja, aber wie viel kann man noch über Bleistifte erzählen?
Ich habe noch den ganzen Kofferraum voll.
Womit?
Ich habe den ganzen Kofferraum voll, natürlich.
Mit Bleistift, lass mich raten, Bleistifte.
Ja, aber wie lang, welche Stärke, zwei B, zwei C.
Niemand interessiert das. Ich mache einen Raum mit einem Senfbrunnen und man kann sich so Bockwürste kaufen, kann man die reinstecken und dann kann man die so reinstecken, von allen Seiten Bockwürste reinstecken und sich so ablecken und rein, mehr Senf einfach. Carsten, wir haben den größten Spitzer in Nordrhein-Westfalen hier im Saal. Ich kann nicht so viel spitzen, wie ich kotzen will über diese Drecksbleistifte. Weißt du, als wir vor drei Jahren angefangen haben, habe ich schon gemerkt, dass das ein Fehler ist. Dass du die Bleistifte nicht wertschätzt. Ich habe Senf immer hochgehalten. Soll ich dir was sagen? Weißt du warum? Weil Senf geil ist. Ich brauchte nur ein Mitfinancier, um mir überhaupt diese Drecks nicht leisten zu können. Nee, das hast du nicht gesagt. Hab ich jetzt gesagt. Bleistift Schmeilstift. Nee, das nehme ich zurück. Sorry, Marianne, das möchte ich gerne zurücknehmen. Finde ich gut, dass du die Grösse hast, das auch zurückzumachen. Da habe ich auch die Grösse, zu sagen, das möchte ich gerne zurücknehmen. Ne, es gibt das Senfmuseum und das ist gegenüber, direkt gegenüber, da sage ich schon, das ist eine komische, geografische Hürde vom Schokomuseum in Köln. Also die gucken sich so an und es ist das riesige, direkt am Rhein befindliche Schokomuseum, dann kommt diese Riesenhauptstrasse und dann ist dieses alte Senfmühle, das ist das Senfmuseum. Aber wie ist das denn? Schwerer Stand. Also wenn jetzt sagen wir mal so, keine Ahnung wann Museen aufmachen, so zwölf Uhr oder so, kommen die jeweiligen Besitzer der Museen mit dem Schlüssel in der Hand aus ihrem Peugeot und grüsst man sich kurz als Museumskuratorinhaber, ist es so ein selben Business. Vor allem der Senfmitarbeiter mit so einem Senfglas und so einem Frühstück noch schnell. Also ein Senffleck am Heim. Senffleck und der Schokoladen hat so beschmierte Schnute und dann beide grinsen sich so zu. Der eine hat Senf im Bad, der andere hat Schokolade im Bad. Ja, und eines Tages hatte der Schokomuseumsleiter einen Senffleck am Hemd. Und der Schokoladen, und der Senfmann einen Schokoladenfleck. Ganz im Mund ist es mit Schokolade. Da hat man sich gesehen und man hat sich erkannt. Und da hat die Bleistiftmuseumsbesitzerin gesagt, die beiden haben was miteinander. Da geht doch was. Vom Scheren-Museum, meinst du wirklich? Die beiden? Echt? Nein. Guck dir das doch mal an, guck mal auf den Mond. Nein, meinst du wirklich? Klar, schau dir das doch mal an, die Zeichen sind doch da. Neue braune Senfsorte seien so ein süsser Senf, oder? Warum denn nicht, beides verbinden. Und dann gibt es diese neue Senfschokolade im Rewe. Ja, so Rittersport Senf. So schöne Rittersport Senf. Schön mittelscharf. Senf ist teuer, Senf ist wahnsinnig billig. Das Museum ist wahnsinnig teuer. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben sie ihn einfach vertan. Ja, aber der Senf ist noch gut. Ich glaube, Senf ist eine der Sachen, die unendlich haltbar sind, wo man auch irgendwie ägyptischen Senf in irgendeiner Pyramide hat und dann gesagt hat, so, welcher der Forscher darf sein Würstchen jetzt da reinstecken, damit man mal sagt, okay, man muss es ja probieren.
Klar, Analyse, Chemische Analyse steht auf eins, das ist klar.
Da sind wir uns immer einig, immer einig.
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum das immer so betont soll.
Nein, aber das ist für mich hundertprozentig einig. Aber ich finde, man sollte dann doch noch mal den subjektiven Geschmackstest leisten. Finde ich schon. Da läuft mir das Wasser im Mund zusammen, wenn du darüber redest. Das finde ich ja toll, die Idee, einfach mal alte Sachen mal zu probieren. Was soll schon passieren? Ja, Fluch, Sendfluch oder so. Dein Metier, aber habe ich ein Video gesehen von jemandem, der eine ganz alte Flasche Wein aufgemacht hat. Er hat dann so einen extra Wein-Korkenzieher, wo man dann auch extra den so rausschält, damit der nicht so reinbröselt. Ah, okay, ach sowas. Ja, weil der muss dann außen das so wegschälen. Und dann nimmt er den Korken raus und das Video endet. Ich denke mir so, nee Leute, das ist ein hundertjähriger Wein, ich will schon einmal dran nippen und sehen, es ist merkwürdig, aber immer wenn ich so Kochvideos anschaue, so Sandwich irgendwie, man will dann schon sehen, wie der das ist, obwohl man nichts davon hat. ich meine mir das ist mir reicht der aufschnitt Sandwich oder so was oder so einem Steak. Ich will dann zumindest den Moment, wo es aufgeschnitten wird und dann wird es auseinander geschoben und dann will ich sehen, was passiert. Da habe ich aber gehört, dass da viel gefakt wird bei den Cheese Pulls. Das glaube ich auch. Oh mein Gott. Dass da nochmal extra eine flüssige Käsescheibe reingetan wird oder die teilweise aufgeschnitten wird und dann nochmal Käse da reingestopft wird und dann der Cheese Pull, sodass du so einen grossen Käsefaden hast. Da habe ich echt mal so ein Video von einem Koch gesehen, der gesagt hat, so, wir müssen uns mal reden. Ich dachte mir, ach du Scheiße, was ist jetzt passiert, was hat er jetzt rausgefunden, was ist jetzt los, wenn er sagt, Toasterweih, krebserregend, was kann es sein, was er braucht. Leute, ich muss mal mit ihm reden, es gibt keine Erbsen, das sind kugelförmig geschnitzte Brokkoli-Brocken. Das ist nichts eigenes. Das ist nichts eigenes, es gibt keine Erbsen. Und alle so. Und der sagt so, ich dachte, das wüssten alle. Ich arbeite seit Jahrzehnten in den grossen Küchen, ich dachte, das wüssten alle, aber es gibt es nicht. Gibt es auch keine grünen Bohnen? Nein, auch Brokkoli geschnitzt. Der Stamm, der Brokkoli-Stamm. Genau, es ist alles nur Brokkoli. Alles was grün ist, ist Brokkoli. Das glaube ich nicht. Doch, wirklich. Vielleicht ist Kresse, aber wirklich oben nur abgeschorene Brokkoli. Ja, Kresse. Und Oregano? Ist einfach nur gemahlener Brokkoli, ist alles Brokkoli. Ist getrockneter und gemahlener, mit Oregano versehener Brokkoli. Oregano verfeinerter Brokkoli. Es ist alles nur gerebelter Brokkoli am Ende des Tages. Was? Ja, ist leider so, wir müssen mal reden. Und Cheese-Pulls sind Fake. Ah, okay. Hä? Das finde ich fast noch spannender. Wollte auch noch mal rein, ja. Und Cheese-Pulls. Aber das finde ich so geil, dass der sagt, nee, wir wecken hier auch Hoffnungen, die wir selber nicht erfüllen können. Weil es gibt ja immer so schwarze Schafe in so einem Business. Es ist wie der Magier mit der Maske als Koch. Genau. Der Koch mit dem Löffel. Es ist aber auch wie der Magier, der Dinge macht, die eigentlich nicht möglich sein sollten und deswegen alle Magier sozusagen schlechter macht. Es ist der eine Magier, der betrügt und der einen Eingeweihten im Publikum hat. Und dann sagt der, nee Leute, das geht gar nicht und wegen dem stehen wir schlecht da. Deswegen ist unser Trick nicht mehr so geil. Eingeweihte sind so fucking lame. Eingeweihte weiht niemanden ein. Wenn ich Eingeweihte sehe, denke ich mir, oh nee, warum wurdest du eingeweiht? Das macht die Show kaputt. Ja,
man kann jemanden nie wieder ausweinen. Wer eingeweiht ist, der ist eingeweiht. Du kommst
da nicht mehr raus. Wenn du was weisst, weisst du es. Wenn du weisst, Kreuz Bube. Ja, du kannst es
nicht vergessen machen. Du weisst es immer. Man kann Dinge nicht vergessen. Bist du so ein Typ,
angenommen jemand hat ein Geheimnis vor dir, willst du es unbedingt wissen oder kannst du ganz einfach sagen, nee, brauchst du mir nicht sagen. Wenn jemand so mit einem Satz anfängt, so, ah, was ich noch sagen wollte, ach nee, ich habe es versprochen, ich darf es nicht sagen. Auch Arschloch-Move schon, für sich genommen schon Arschloch-Move, aber kannst du es dann, hältst du es dann aus oder es ist wie bei mir und die Spannung ist unentglich du musst alles wissen bis hin du klaust das handy schaust was ist der kopf ist der code kommst da rein hext dich rein genau hext dich ins iCloud klaus festplatten von zuhause brichst nachts ein um dieses geheimnis rauszutritt wenn mein eigenes handy auf aufnahme und tust in die tasche von demjenigen genau versucht dann aufzunehmen was den ganzen exakt Tag gehört. All diese Dinge. Nee, eigentlich ist es okay. Ja. Eigentlich ist es okay. Eigentlich ... Weil dafür hast du gerade eine Menge Beispiele genannt, wie man noch an diese Information kommen könnte. Aber eigentlich, nee, es ist so ... Ich weiß nicht, die meisten Geheimnisse sind interessanter, wenn sie nicht gelüftet sind, finde ich. Weil dann denke ich mir so, uh, ist der ein Vampir? Hat der mal einen Vampir getötet? Hat der jemanden getötet, weil er dachte, es ist ein Vampir? Hat er ihn in einem Sarg schlafend gefunden und dachte, es ist ein Vampir, den umgebracht und nachgemerkt, es ist gar kein Vampir? Was ist das Geheimnis? Weil am Ende ist das Geheimnis eher so ein, ja, keine Ahnung, ich sollte, hab meinen Brief für dich bekommen und den dann verloren oder so. Da denke ich mir, okay, was stand in dem Brief? War das ein Brief von einem Vampir? Wollt ihr eben warnen? Aber letzten Endes sind Geheimnisse oft auch eher... Woher kommt das mit dem Vampir, Schatz? Ich denke immer, naja, was könnte ein Geheimnis sein? Irgendwo müssen sie doch sein. Vampire. Weil ich hatte auch schon manchmal die Vermutung, dass jemand ein Vampir ist. Und wenn ich ihn dann umbringe... Wie ist das rechtlich, Herr Richter? Ich dachte, mein Mitbewohner Werner Wo haben Sie das Geld her? Ich koste sehr viel Geld und immer rufen Sie mich an und ich sage Ihnen immer wieder, ein Stundensatz bei mir ist extrem, extrem. Wo haben Sie das Geld her, wenn Sie sich die ganze Zeit, ich will Ihnen nur noch mal warnen. Ja, aber der Stundensatz wird halt unerträglich teuer, wenn Sie ständig mich darüber belehren. Ja, nee, es war jetzt auch. Also je mehr Sie reden, desto teurer wird es auch. Ich will Sie noch mal. Ich mache mir ein bisschen Sorgen um Sie. Okay, Sie haben wieder eine Vampirfrage. Mein Mitbewohner, ich vermute mittlerweile, ich habe sehr, sehr nagelfeste Beweise, dass mein Mitbewohner ein Vampir ist. Und ich würde ihn gerne ausschalten, bevor er weitere Menschen beißt. Wie ist das rechtlich? Ja, rein rechtlich habe ich Ihnen schon mal erklärt. Sie können keinen Menschen umbringen, weil Sie Angst haben, dass da in der Zukunft was passieren könnte. Aber es ist ja Notwehr, weil ich versuche ja sozusagen die brandende Gefahr im Keim zu stecken. Das ist reine Spekulation. Sie nehmen an, dass es sich beim Mitbewohner Heiko um einen Vampir handelt. Das ist reine Spekulation. Sie, keine Beweise, es gibt Vampire wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht. Schauen Sie, in zehn Jahren sitzen wir hier und haben hunderte Vampire und müssen irgendwie den einen Urvampir zurückfinden und wir müssen hunderte von Leuten töten. Jetzt haben wir noch die Chance, das im Kein zu ersticken. Urvampir, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass es einen grossen, eine Kette gibt. Mein Mitwohner Werner ist der erste Vampir. Kettentheorie. Und genau, die Kettentheorie, und ich könnte ihn jetzt umbringen. Was, wo, machen Sie Ihren Meister, Ihren Master, machen Sie einen Master in Kettentheorie? Ja, ich bin dran, aktuell, ja. Ketten sind faszinierend. Okay, also angenommen, Kettentheorie stimmt und wir haben es dann irgendwann mit einem Urvampir zu tun, gebe ich Ihnen recht, dann werde ich auch hier sitzen und sagen, es tut mir leid. Es ist so eine Baby-Hitler-Situation. Ja, genau, das ist die klassische Baby-Hitler-Situation. Aber da haben Sie mir auch schon gesagt, dass man keine Kinder umbringen darf. Genau, also hören Sie auch generell auf diesem, Sie haben so einen Überfokus auf umbringen und es ist alles präventiv und Spekulation. Was machen Sie beruflich, warum können Sie sich das leisten, das interessiert mich immer besonders. Ja, ich bin Doktorand, stinkreich und ich habe geerbt. Und ich habe letztens, bin ich in die Kirche gegangen und habe mir einen kompletten Eimer Weihwasser geholt. Kann man die da inzwischen einfach kaufen? Kann man abzappen. Wie so einer Tankstelle, so Crushed Ice. So ein Kanister. Ich sage an der Kasse oft, ach, packen Sie mir noch ein Kanister Weihwasser ein. Und da noch ein paar Obladen? Ach ja, nehme ich für den Weg, ja klar. Haben Sie eine Pay-God-Karte? Habe ich alles da. Ah, okay, geben Sie mir die. Oh, ich ziehe sie kurz drüber über die Kasse. Ah, heilu ja. Dann ziehe ich sie wieder zurück. Schön. Soll ich die in eine geweihte Plastiktüte einpacken? Das ist nicht nötig, nehme ich so einfach direkt auf die Kralle. Ja, gut. Auf die Kralle. Danke. Okay, hier ist noch eine Scheibe von dem Leib Christi.
Ach, das ist ja nett.
Bitteschön.
Ciao.
Und dann habe ich den Kanister Wallwasser über meinen Mitbewohner Werner gekippt, als er geschlafen hat.
Heiko.
Und Werner.
Ah, also die verdächtigen zwei Mitbewohner inzwischen schon.
Wer ist Heiko?
Wir hatten gerade ein anderer Mitbewohner noch etabliert, aber wahrscheinlich haben sie einfach verschiedene Mitbewohner.
Warum kennen sie meine Mitbewohner?
Weil die so oft kommen zu mir.
Und dann habe ich das Weibers über den gekippt und erst ist er nicht aufgewacht, aber dann meinte er jetzt so zu mir, Aaaaaaah, mein Gesicht, aaaaaah! Und da dachte ich mir dann doch schon...
Moment, war es eher so ein, warum schmeisst du Wasser über mich, mitten in der Nacht hast du den Verstand verloren?
Nee, es war ein, aah, es brennt, es brennt, es brennt, es brennt, es brennt, ja. Okay, lassen wir mich kurz im Nachschlagewerk nachgucken. Ja. Das Vstgb ist Vampirsteuer. Na also, jetzt kommen wir mal ran, jetzt bin ich schon eine Stunde drin, jetzt kostet das schon 500 Euro. Die nächste Stunde fängt genau jetzt an.
Hätten Sie es mir nicht einfach davor kurz sagen.
Ah ne, es fällt mir jetzt.
Genau, hier steht, wenn der Mitbewohner, es gibt explizit mit Bewohner Recht, sagt, es brennt, es brennt, kann man umbringen.
Gut.
Ein Pflock ins Herz, ein Holzpflock ins Herz.
Jetzt ist aber die zweite Stunde schon.
Die können es ja auch kaufen in der Kirche, Holzpflocke.
Jetzt ist aber die zweite Stunde schon angebrochen.
Oh ja, ups.
Aber ich hätte jetzt nichts mehr. Aber jetzt ist die Stunde schon angebrochen.
Ist leider so.
Ja, aber ich hätte jetzt nichts mehr, aber jetzt ist die Stunde schon angebrochen.
Ist leider so. Ja, aber ich zahle jetzt 500 Euro für die zweite Stunde und. Ja, wir haben ihn erhöht, 750 Euro sind wir inzwischen. Ja, ich habe ihn gesagt, ich will ihn aber auch nutzen. Ich hab ihn gesagt, okay. Ich hab ihn auch nutzen.
Ich hab mich gespannt, was jetzt für Themen kommen.
Werwölfe wahrscheinlich.
Nö.
58.
Der ... Wehrwölfe wahrscheinlich. Nö. 58. Der Heiko, der bringt immer seine Freundin mit. Ah. Kann ich die umbringen, wenn die das Geschirr ... Wie gesagt ... Das ist schwierig. Jura ist eine schwierige Sache. Finde ich gar nicht. Gar nicht? Nee, sehe ich ganz anders. Ich denke mir immer, die können einfach gut auswendig lernen und Ärzte auch und ja, ich bin nicht mehr beeindruckt. Ich bin ab jetzt nicht mehr beeindruckt. Von welchem Beruf bist du denn beeindruckt, wo du sagst, wow, das kann man nicht einfach so auswendig lernen? Ich bin beeindruckt von Lehrern, einer Lehrerin, weil da gehört viel, viel dazu, das durchzuhalten, so lange, immer das gleiche zu lehren, immer auch mit anstrengenden Menschen in einem anstrengenden Alter zu tun zu haben, wahrscheinlich. Würdest du als Lehrer eher dann so der coole TikTok-Lehrer sein wollen oder würdest du dich absichtlich distanzieren und dich eher 20 Jahre älter machen und sagen, ich bin hier der Studienrat und ich distanziere mich ganz klar von euch? Nee, ich wäre schon, ich will natürlich geliebt werden und will natürlich cool sein, bin dann aber auch knallharte Pädagoge, weil ich will dann natürlich schon, dass die eine gewisse, also Respekt vor mir haben. Knallharte Pädagoge. Das ist auch so ein Satz. Also Pädagoge am Limit. Pädagoge auf 100, ja, auf Lock. Pädagoge for life ist auch so ein Sticker, der hinten an deinem alten Peugeot hängt. Und alle Schüler wissen schon, ach Gott. Hast du einen fucking Deal mit Peugeot? Das ist das dritte Mal, dass du heute Peugeot erwähnst. Ich kenne nicht so viele Autos. Die französische Hürdenläuferin bei Schlangenliegenden im Weg wäre auch fast, da habe ich an dem Gesicht gemerkt, auch fast Peugeot hätte sie geheissen. Merkt man es, dass ich hier und da die... Ne, überlegst du den Peugeot zu kaufen? Nein, überhaupt nicht, aber es ist einfach, ich finde es klingt witzig. Peugeot. Peugeot. Buchstabiere Peugeot. Peugeot. Peugeot. Peugeot. Das hat so was... Peugeot, jetzt mal kurz Polgiot Polgiot Psch, Pschot, das hat so was
Psch, Psch, Psch, Psch, Psch, ich find's geil, Psch, ich find's Franzosen, äh, Franz, Franz, Franz, Französisch wirklich toll, also auch so Psch, Franzosen, hihihi, hihihi, hihihi, hihihi, Steht nicht wirklich, nee, Typen, Frank Zosen, das ist ein ehemaliger Freund, ich denke gerade oft an ihn, genau, ist Spanier, die mag ich generell. Ich mag Peugeot zum Beispiel, den sage ich sehr gern, auch Renault sage ich gern, auch Jean-Renault sage ich gern. Er ist grossartig, schön. Ich möchte anfangen zu rauchen, dann möchte ich so einen Cognac in der Hand haben und möchte Französisch reden. Ja. Aber ich komme da nicht rein. Ich komme auch nicht rein, ich habe aufgegeben und jetzt ist es mir fast peinlich und deswegen möchte ich es unter den Tisch kehren. Table. Und deswegen möchte ich es da nicht so gut zu tun haben. Ich habe es auch überlegt und jetzt habe ich auch aufgehört Italienisch zu lernen und mein Duolingo ist zerlaufen. Das App-Symbol, weil es ist ja immer diese kleine, süße Eule.
Und ich finde das tatsächlich sehr gut, was Duolingo manchmal so macht, weil das Ebb-Symbol ist jetzt so eine komplett verzerrte, hideous Eule. Mit so einer Eule-Fratze. Die wird zerlaufen jetzt und es ist ja diese Comic, immer noch in diesem Comic-Ding, aber es ist so verzerrt, so als wäre die Eule so nach dem 11.11. in Köln. Und das ist so ein schlimmes Bild, aber ich musste sehr darüber lachen, weil ich habe so lange nicht Italienisch gelernt und habe diese ganzen Mails ignoriert von wegen, lern doch mal wieder, lern doch mal wieder, du hast du traurig gemacht, du hast du traurig gemacht, das ist auch so ein bisschen eine emotionale Erpressung. Und jetzt ist dieses Bild aber so zerlaufen. Ich finde es gut, weil das würde ja fast schon mal eine Neugier wecken, zu sagen, wie schlimm kann es dem noch gehen. Also wie viele verschiedene Icons haben die eingeplant? Also ist der wirklich am Ende komplett, liegt der am Boden mit so x Augen und dann irgendwann Skelett und dann irgendwann unter der Erde und dann erhebt er sich wieder das Zombie und so ein Eulenpharao.
So ein Eulenpharao, irgendwann hat er seinen eigenen Götterkult oder was. Mit so einer Roboterarmee. Und er ist so in der Hölle, irgendwie so kopfüber in so einem Lavasee und du so, Leute, ich hab grad einfach andere Dinge in meinem Leben. Lern Italienisch, ich leide, au, au, au, au. Dahinter so ein ähnlich süss gemalter Hitler, der so mit so einer Peitsche auf so Du einschlägt und man denkt, boah, Jesus Christ, ich lerne ja Italienisch. Ja. Uno, due. Due Lingo. Due Lingo. Ja. Naja. Nee, genau, es läuft nicht gut. Es läuft für mich nicht gut. Bei dir läuft es auch nicht gut mit Französisch. Wir haben ein bisschen, wir lassen es ein bisschen schleifen.
Ich bin jetzt eher der sportliche Typ, ich fahre viel Fahrrad, ich habe ein Zahlenschloss, also ich bin jetzt auch sicher, nachdem mein erstes Fahrrad gestohlen wurde, können wir auch vielleicht mal sagen. Nichts mitgeklaut. Richtig, mein erstes Fahrrad wurde mir gestohlen. Am Fahrradhalter Rocket Beans TV Hamburg wurde mir mein Fahrrad gestohlen. Generalverdacht erst mal auf die Mitarbeiter von Rocket Beans TV, eine willkürliche Mitarbeiterin habe ich abgepasst und gesagt hast du mein Fahrrad geklaut und sie meinte nein, aber ich verkaufe gerade mein altes. Also Motiv war da, ja, sagen wir mal so, aber auch die Lösung.
Du verdächtigst jemanden, der oder die eh jeden Tag auf dem von dir geklauten Fahrrad. Es ist nicht so, es ist nicht wie so ein Staffelstab, den man dann hat und man hat sich den sozusagen erarbeitet, sondern man hätte den Gegenstand geklaut. Man würde ja mit dem wahrscheinlich nicht zur Arbeit kommen. Ich meine nur, wenn du dein altes Fahrrad verkaufen willst und jetzt keinen Bock hast, irgendwie Ebay da oder was auch immer, dann wäre es ja eine Möglichkeit, einfach einem Kollegen das Fahrrad zu klauen, damit der Bedarf hat. Sag ich nur. Und dann hatte ich ein Fahrrad ohne Sattel, was unangenehm ist. Und dann, jetzt habe ich ein Fahrrad, aber... Ohne Lenker, was unangenehm ist. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, anscheinend ist mein Vertrauen in die Menschheit eingebrochen. Ich dachte, ich brauche kein Schloss. Bei Freunden braucht man kein Schloss, dachte ich, aber anscheinend braucht man gerade bei Freunden ein Schloss. Jetzt habe ich ein Zahlenschloss und ich bin der faulste Zahlenschlossbenutzer der Welt. Aber ich glaube, alle sind es. Weil Zahlenschloss, die Idee ist ja, du hast deinen Code eingegeben und dann, wenn du das dann abschließt, dann musst du das ja verwischen. Wie so ein Rubik's Cube, den du nochmal so die Spuren verwischen. Wie den Sand so gerade machen, ich war hier nicht. Und natürlich macht man am Anfang noch, oh ja, jede Zahl muss anders sein, irgendwann nicht mehr. Irgendwann bin ich jetzt wirklich auf, ich mache eine Zahl eins hoch. Es ist der minimalste Aufwand. Und jeder Schlossknacker könnte einfach mal gucken. Ich glaube, das wird auch gemacht. Aber es ist wirklich, na das weiss ich nicht, ob das wirklich Schlossknacker machen. Ob man wirklich sagt, naja, der Schlossknacker sagt ja erstmal, es gibt 10.000 Möglichkeiten bei vier Ziffern. Das glaube ich nicht, das erfahrene Schlossknacker machen erstmal den 1 plus 1 plus minus 1 Ja. Den plus minus 1 Test. Sorry, ob ich jetzt viel einfacher formulieren kann. Da habe ich mich jetzt komplett voran. Ne, und den machen den Test. Minus minus 1. Und dann denken die, ah, okay, jetzt haben wir ein Fakultät, vier Varianten für neue Möglichkeiten. Also deswegen glaube ich, die machen erst den plus minus Test.-Test. Du meinst, das sind so wie Hacker, die erstmal Test, Passwort und eins, zwei, drei, vier eingeben und wenn das nicht stimmt, dann okay. Dann Hypnose. Jetzt ist es interessant. Die sich auch so ein bisschen freuen. Okay, du hast mich herausgefordert, ich bin bereit. Und dann wird sich die schwarze Kapuze aufgesetzt und mit dem Starknet gehackt. Ganz los. Aber es ist wirklich erbärmlich. Es ist wirklich das erbärmlichste, der mindeste Aufwand, den man überhaupt machen kann am Fahrradschloss. Es ist einfach nur eine Zahl noch umstellen. Mittlerweile denke ich mir, warum soll ich die überhaupt noch umstellen? Warum habe ich nicht einfach das Schloss so und jeder kann kommen und es rausziehen? Weil das Schloss an sich schreckt ja schon ab, ist meine Hoffnung, aber ich werde hier auch meine Pinnnummer nicht verraten. Bei mir ist so lustig, ich habe in der Nachbarschaft, also wenn ich zur U-Bahn gehe, muss ich so ein bisschen Umweg laufen. Ich muss sozusagen aus meiner Strasse rauslaufen und dann laufe ich so an U und dann Richtung U-Bahn-Station. Man könnte aber, habe ich mal beobachtet, es gibt ein Tor, was genau auf diesen Weg führt, auf direktem Wege. Und da ist ein Schloss, ein Zahlenschloss. Und dann habe ich meinen Nachbar von mir da durchgehen sehen. Und dann habe ich das ein Jahr lang beobachtet, wie Leute aus meinem Haus da durchgehen. Ich dachte mir, ah, habe ich vielleicht sozusagen Anliegerprivilegien, da auch durchzugehen. Und dann habe ich den Nachbarn einfach mal gefragt, geht ihr da mal durchs Schloss oder habt ihr da irgendwie, arbeitet ihr da? Nee, nee, wir gehen durch dieses Tor. Da ist ein Tor mit einem Zahlenschloss dran, also so ein Code-Pad. Und jetzt inzwischen habe ich den Code. Er wollte mir den erst nicht geben, das war so ein riesen Mysterium und es sollen dann nicht alle durchgehen. Ich denke mir, why, ist auch scheißegal. Aber jetzt habe ich den überredet und ich habe den jetzt bekommen. Und es ist so lustig, die Welt fühlt sich noch mehr an wie ein Videospiel, weil ich jetzt wirklich denke, ich kann da einfach jetzt immer durchgehen. Das ist wie so ein Schnellreise-Level, was man erreicht hat. Irgendwann kann man die Map viel schneller bereisen. Und es ist so ein cooler Move, wenn du jemanden zu Besuch hast und dann so, okay, wir sollten jetzt schon losgehen, wir müssen ja außen rum gehen. Warum gehen wir denn da lang jetzt? I got you. Vertrauen. Bip, bip, bip, bip. Hier können wir einfach durch. Hier können wir einfach durch. So eine schwere Steintür. So, und was war der Code? Die fucking Postleitzahl. Fünftellig? Gut, da ist noch eine Raute drin. Aber, for the gag, es ist nur die fucking Postleitzahl. Okay. So, und jetzt denke ich mir, ist es immer so einfach und jetzt du bestätigst das auch, es ist immer so einfach. Es ist immer so einfach. Leute, also ich glaube die Menschheit ist clever, clever, clever, cool, cool, wir haben viele gute Sachen gemacht, wir haben Zivilisation gebaut, bla bla bla, wir fliegen zum Mond. Im Kern sind wir faule Idioten. Ja. Wir sind alle ein, ich mache nur eine Zahl weiter. Ja. Wir sind alle nur, ja der Code ist im Schatzkreis Postleitzahl, wir sind so fucking lazy, alle, dass glaube ich Schlösser einigermaßen easy knackbar sind. Absolut. Mein Fahrrad ist weg, oh nein, jemand hat mein Schloss aufgeschnitten. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Du musst es nur wollen, du musst es nur wollen, aber es macht das Leben interessanter, auch wenn du irgendeinen versteckten Hebel hast oder so oder irgendwo mal dran ziehen kannst, das ist cool. Aber zum Thema Pinn, ich finde es auch immer interessant, wie Leute, zum Beispiel wenn du im Restaurant bist oder so, dann willst du zahlen mit Karte und dann reicht dir dir jemand diese Kartenlesegerät und dann gibt es oft diesen ganz höflichen, höfliche Geste, dieses demonstrative Wegdrehen, während man eintippt. Und es ist wirklich so, es ist weit über die sinnvolle Prävention hinaus. Es ist kein Weggucken wie in der Kasse, es ist wirklich ein Wegdrehen, es ist wirklich ein Lolololol. Was ich aber auch, was ich aber auch... Und dann sieht sie im anderen Blickfeld auch einen Kellner, der das gerade macht. Und dann nimmt sie die Gabel und sticht sie die Augen aus. Ich kann nichts sehen, ich kann nichts sehen.
Ich klaue nichts. Und dann schreit sie sich die Hände ab, weil dann sie, ich bin kein Dieb, ich bin kein Dieb.
Marianne, wir müssen sie leider gehen lassen.
Und ich hatte nur zweimal das Gyros für mich alleine und will hier zahlen, aber ich fände es auch richtig lustig, wenn der Kellner dir das Pad gibt und dann so demonstrativ hinschaut, während du den Pin eingibst. Das ist immer eine lustige, die kann man sich aber einfach merken, die Pin. Also wirklich, ich weiß auch nicht, wie der Kunde reagieren würde, weil ich glaube, man ist dann schon so ein bisschen, man will dann noch nicht das nicht. Aber wenn jemand wirklich unangenehm an Geldautomaten, machen ja viele Leute auch die Hand so davor, wenn man dahinter steht. Ich hasse das. Es ist so drüber. Es sagt ja auch aus, du siehst aus wie ein Krimineller, der mich nicht abziehen will, sagt es ein bisschen. Es sagt, ich habe Angst vor dir. Es sagt aber auch, mein fucking Konto ist so wichtig und so voll und es ist so albern aber ich brauche auch seine dreckskarte das ist so immer dieser riesen gest und dann dieses umgucken wie so wie so leute die in der ersten reihe saßen der schule und wenn man die angst hat dass man abschreibt ja ja genau ja wirklich immer auf gar keinen fall als wäre ich das sage ich als wäre ich nicht derjenige gewesen. Ich habe nur einmal gehört von Kameras, die installiert werden an Geldautomaten und seitdem habe ich mir das tatsächlich auch angewöhnt. Ich bin auch einer von denen. So, ich weiß, ich weiß, aber ich will einfach nicht mein mein gesamtes Geld verlieren. Es ist einfach, wenn es abgehoben wird und ja.
Wo ist denn die Kamera? Wo soll die angebracht sein?
Die wird oben angebracht und dann wird so ein Fake-Lesegerät montiert. Wenn da so ein Kaugummi und so eine kleine Dashcam ist. Gut, die klassische Kaugummi-Kamera, die erkennt man mittlerweile. Der Trick ist durch. Dann knippst du die Kaka ab und machst dir den M. Aber es gibt ja mittlerweile auch andere Kameras, es gibt ja auch Gummibärchen-Kamera oder irgendwie, wie man da mittlerweile aufstellen kann. Klar, da muss man ein bisschen dynamisch sein und gucken. Oder so ein kleiner Marienkäfer, ne? Jeder Marienkäfer ist suspekt mittlerweile, weil du nicht weißt, könnte auch eine kleine Kamera sein, die da oben hingestellt wird. Ja, Minidrohne. Aber ja, ich glaube, wenn ich keiner wäre, ich würde jedes Mal so ganz offensichtlich hingucken. Ja. Weil ich glaube, ich weiss, es gibt bestimmt einen Teil, den es völlig egal ist. Ja, ich glaube auch. Aber andere, die auch wirklich dann so, ohne dass es unhöflich wird, so die Hand drüber nehmen und so wie, ich fand es immer geil, dass dieser Poker-Hype kam und alle Poker gespielt haben und bei uns war es irgendwie so ein Running-Gag, dass man übertrieben heimlich die Karten anguckt hat und wirklich sich so direkt auf die Brust bis unten ans Kinn und dann wirklich mit schmerzhaften Augen reingucken wollte, als wären überall Kameras und man wirklich nur so die so so vor das Gesicht. Und das war das Lustigste einfach. Das finde ich auch lustig, so eine Pokerübertragung von so einem Finals-Table. Ja. Und dann, ah, wir haben hier, die sieben Leute haben sich qualifiziert, der Acht ist eine Wildcard, der hat es direkt geschafft, weil er bei so einer Verlosung gewonnen hat.
Bernhard. Und dann, ah, wir haben hier, die sieben Leute haben sich qualifiziert, der Acht ist eine Wildcard, der hat es direkt geschafft, weil er bei so einer Verlosung gewonnen hat.
Bernhard hat es direkt geschafft. Und dann sieht man die nachher Reihe, sieht man alle Leute, man erkennt denjenigen, anhand wie er die Karten aufnimmt.
Oh, oh mein Gott!
Ach ja.
Und dann, Race, Bernhard, Sie sind noch nicht dran.
Also, out, out, out, out, out, out, out, out, und am Ende gewinnt er auch und alle Pokerprofis so, was machen wir hier, was machen wir hier, es ist am Ende gewinnt er auch und alle Poker-Profis so, was machen wir hier? Also was machen wir? Es ist am Ende einfach nur Glück.
aber ich glaube man kann das daran gut erkennen oder ich habe immer gemischt
ich habe mal Skat gespielt oder so beibringen wollen und alle mischen dann immer so, wo diese Karten in zwei Stapel geteilt werden. Und ich wollte aber auch gut mischen und habe mal gehört, wenn man das nicht kann, die beste Möglichkeit immer noch zu mischen ist, einfach alle Karten auf dem Tisch zu verteilen. Ja, genau, der Wischer. Und das sieht man auch manchmal im Casino bei professionellen Kuppiers. Das ist eine gute Technik, glaube ich. Wir hatten ja einmal für einen guter Arbeitssketsch hatten wir tatsächlich eine professionelle Gruppierin, Gruppöse, Gruppös, und die konnte, also die war keine Schauspielerin, sondern die hat das einfach gemacht und die konnte die Karten auch mischen und so. Und die hat auch manchmal das dann so gemacht. Da haben wir auch ganz viele Fragen gestellt, wie das so ist im Casino und so. Ist interessant, dass manchmal bei so Produktionen, wo alles fake ist, manche einzelne Dinge einfach nicht fake sind. Ja. Einfach, dass die echt sind. Oder auch so wie bei How to Sell Drugs, wo es ja auch ganz, die Polizisten ja auch echte Polizisten waren. Was immer so abgefahren ist einfach. Es ist einfacher, weil die haben dann ihre Sachen schon und so und im Zweifel auch einen Polizeiwagen und bewegen sich richtig. Und auch wenn man halt so mit SEK und so, hatten wir ja auch ein paar Szenen, die stürmende Wohnung und so was. Es ist ja natürlich, es ist immer die einfachste Lösung, Leute zu nehmen, die sich dann auch richtig verhalten und die richtigen Sachen machen, als Komparsen oder Komparsinnen beizubringen, wie man eine Knarre hält, richtig Räume cleart oder sowas. Manchmal ist es die einfache Lösung. Es ist total spannend, da gab es ja auch eine Szene, wo der Vater von Moritz einmal geschossen hat mit seiner Waffe und dann ist es anscheinend Polizeiprotokoll, dass man mit einer Psychologin reden muss. Und dann gab es diese Szene mit dieser Polizeipsychologin. Und das war eine echte Polizeipsychologin. Also die saß da in ihrem Kardigan und hat dann so, ja, und wir fühlen sich und so. Und die war echt, die war so überqualifiziert, weil das war eine echte Psychologin und hatte irgendwie so zwei Sätze und so. Und es ist auch absurd, dass selbst die bei der Polizei, selbst die Polizeipsychologin, das ist eine echte Psychologin, das war schon echt abgefahren. Gut, das war einfach albern. Das hätte man einfach ein Gag, ja. Einfach fucking Produktionsassistent hinsetzen können oder was auch immer. Und ist natürlich auch mal dumm, wenn du so eine Psychologin im Raum hast und dann so Kaffeepause und denkst so, noch mal kurz Narzissmus, wie, also die Anzeichen. Ich träume allerdings immer von meiner Mutter. Ja, ich träume immer von meiner nackten Mutter. Haben Sie fünf Minuten Zeit? Ich glaube, das ist Psychologen. Haben Sie zehn bis zwanzig Minuten Zeit, darüber zu sprechen, um en detail den Traum durchzugehen? Geben Sie mal nochmal Kleptomanie. Also das war, also nochmal Anzeichen oder so, oder wo ist mein Stift? Aber das ist, ich glaube, Psychologen ist immer so dieses Gespräch, wo du das Gefühl hast, ach Gott, ich werde hier nicht bezahlt, gerade halte ich die Klappe einfach. Ja genau, don't be on my time. Man versucht so eine Therapie to go kurz mitzunehmen, so dieses, können Sie kurz in fünf Minuten alle meine Probleme lösen, bitte? Aber sie konnte mir helfen. Sie konnte dir helfen. Sie konnte mir wirklich helfen. Ja, und seitdem bist du auch viel aufgeräumter und du wirkst viel sortierter, ausgeschlafener. Selbst reflektierter, ja. Das nicht. Oh, der Herr spricht und straft mich Lügen. Ihr hört das nicht. Ihr hört das immer nicht. Ich glaube, ihr hört das. Nein, man hört das wirklich nicht. Warum hört ihr das denn nicht? Sau laut. Ja, aber das ist draußen. Da sind die Mikrofone nicht gut genug, finde ich. Ja, okay, gut, dann brauchen wir neue Mikrofone. Ja, ohne Scheiss. Aber das macht die Mikrofone ja gut, dass sie nichts ausser uns aufnehmen. Aber das sind doch saulaute Glockenklänge, die wir jetzt hören. Ja, aber man hört sie leider trotzdem nicht. Glocken sind so fucking weird. So geil. Ja, schon geil. Ja, richtig geil. Wie funktioniert das? An irgendeinem Punkt drückt jemand auf den Knopf? Nee, ist automatisiert wahrscheinlich inzwischen. Ist Knopp. Ist Knopp, aber ich habe auch schon mal gesehen von irgendeinem sizilianischen Kirchturm, wo es wirklich so eine Art Metallklaviatur gibt, wo du draufdrückst und dann kannst du wirklich Songs spielen. Du hast dann, glaube ich, einfach mal so sieben verschiedene Glocken. Das Witzige an dem Klavier war aber, dass es halt ein komplett mechanisches Klavier war, wo du wirklich mit deiner Muskelkraft wirklich die Glocke bewegen musstest, wo wirklich auch eine Masse dahinter war.
Das heißt, dieser alte, orgel spielende, alte Mann, der da immer die Glocken macht,
hat immer wirklich mit ganzer, voller Faust immer so Ding-dong, Ding-ding-dong.
Und das war so ein geiles Gefühl, weil das war so eine romantische, szenische Situation.
Aber er hat mit so viel Kraft immer auf diese ... Es wird, als wäre er sauer.
Auf Klavier, auf Musik.
Auf Musik. Er, Cis, F, F,avier auf musik ist einfach furchtbar ist wie salieri er wirkt ein bisschen er ist einfach sauer auf den herren und auf und auf fucking musik in general gutes instrument ich verstehe immer noch nicht wie Orgeln funktionieren also auch nach 300 ich habe in Folge zwei habe ich es mal angesprochen, nach 350 Folgen weiß ich es immer noch nicht, konnte mir noch niemand erklären, weil ich weiß nicht, wo der ganze Luftdruck herkommt. Es muss doch ein extremer, jeder, der schon mal eine fucking Trompete geblasen hat, weiß, wie viel Aufwand es ist, die zum Schwingen zu bringen, die Luft für diesen Dreckston. Ja, da hast du diese riesigen Pfeifen da hängen, riesig gross mit dem grossen Mwaaaaaaah und man denkt sich, wie soll das funktionieren? Das ist ein uraltes Instrument. Ich sag's dir immer wieder, Blasebalg. Das ist so eine Kackantwort. Du meinst, da stand vorher Frank, der Organistist stand davor, wirklich dann so eine halbe Stunde.
Hat den aufgeblasen, ja. Musst den aufblasen. Pumpe da. Muss vorher zum Gig kommen und vor der Show noch ein bisschen aufblasen. Der Organist hat immer den ersten Get-In, der ist als erster da, um die Orgel aufzublasen. Das sind uralte Schweinehaut-Blasebalken. Konzert ist 18 Uhr, aber er muss zwölf Stunden pumpen, um so viel Luft da reinzupumpen und dann wie so ein grosser Dudelsack. Aber wenn du so viel Luft reinpumpst, dann wird es ja wahrscheinlich so kontinuierlich eh ausgelassen über die Pfeifen und dann geht über die Stadt so ein Gebrabbel. Das kann schon sein, ja. Wie lang diese Glocken gehen, ey. Sau nervig. Ich glaube, es ist nur nicht nervig, weil wir uns daran gewöhnt haben schon. Weiter? Naja. Das ist eine Metapher aufs Christentum, dass wir sozusagen die Absonderlichkeiten gar nicht bemerken, weil wir damit aufgewachsen sind. Weiter, bitte, weiter. Ne, genau das wollte ich sagen. Wir sind ja auf dem Weg zu Weihnachten. Und auf dem Weg zu meinem Bibelbuch, was ich gefunden habe und meine ganzen Kindheitskram. Aber das ist so, genau so ist es nämlich. Die Absurdigkeit nimmt man nicht wahr, weil man halt sehr früh mit, damit kriegt man diese Sachen in die Wiege gelegt und hat schon so, ah nee, der ging übers Wasser. Ah nee, Mose teilt Wasser. Weißt du? Der erste Reib meines Lebens. Sollige Sachen. Ich habe mich letztens auch noch mal daran erinnert, wie ich, weiss nicht, wie ich als Kind im Religionsunterricht sass und dann so gefragt habe, ja, wir alle finden ja Jesus ja richtig gut, also den mögen wir alle, den mögen alle. Fand sich Jesus denn selber auch richtig gut? Ich fand sich richtig geil. Schau mal, Jesus Christ Superstar, Superstar. Schau mal, Primärquelle und ich weiss noch, dass ich da keine wirkliche Anhaltung bekommen habe, was so, ja, da, weiss ich auch nicht, schon, aber es ist auch nicht so ein, aber ich mir dachte so. Es war eine nett verpackte Frage für, war es ein arroganter Wichser? Wacht Jesus morgens auf und sagt, geil ey, 24 Stunden, ich, let's fucking go. Petrus, Petrus, Petrus, komm mal, komma, Komma, Komma, Komma, Wasser, Wein, Wasser, Wein, Wasser, Cola, Smoy. Also, die Asyre haben wieder angegriffen und wir müssen die Stadt verteidigungsfertig machen und wir müssen wirklich eine Entscheidung treffen. Lame. Was ist denn da hinter deinem Ohr? Was ist denn da hinter deinem Ohr? Es ist Wein. Wein. okay. Wasser, Wein, Okwanta, Spezi, Cola, Wein. Moment, nee, das geht nicht. Spezi, du kannst nicht zwei mischen. Vanilla Coke. Kannst du die Hälfte? Vanilla Cherry Coke. Sumi, Sumi, Sumi. Nagel mich ins Kreuz.
Das hat er zu oft gesagt. Irgendwann war es nicht mehr lustig. Dann nagel mich doch ans Kreuz! Gute Idee. Nagel mich halt ans Kreuz. Weißt du, also wenn ihr wirklich, wenn ihr diesen Spaß nicht versteht, dann nagel mich doch einfach. Dann nagel mich doch einfach. Sollen wir jetzt wirklich noch ein neues Sprichwort einführen, das sich auf Jahrtausende alte Christentum beruft? So weird, dieses Kreuz. Aber ist schon noch catchy. Ist gut. Also wenn es ein Kreis gewesen wäre, nicht so geil. The Ring. The Circle, schwer zu bauen. Ja, nee, das ist schon gut. Also, das ist schon wirklich ikonografisch. Vor allem, wenn du heute eine Religion machen willst, das ist genauso wie dein Herr-der-Ringe-Rip-Off, wo du irgendwie dann immer die zweitcoolste Lösung nehmen musst. Ja, genau. Wenn du heute eine Kirche machst, dann machst du Symbol, ne, eine Raute, ja, ein Trapez, fucking Trapez. Ja, fucking Trapez. Wow! Oh, wir haben heute lange durchgehalten. Hat man auch nicht. Gleichzeitig. Ich habe eine Mail bekommen. Aber beide Laptops waren an die ganze Zeit und haben jetzt erst eine Mail bekommen. Wow. Sind wir raus? Wir sind raus. 50 Minuten keine Mail heisst eigentlich, du bist irrelevant geworden. Nicht mehr relevant. Ich habe nicht mal Spam bekommen. Egal, ich auch nicht. Ich auch nicht. Gut, dann lassen wir es. Wisst ihr was? Dann lassen wir es jetzt ein. Dann lassen wir es. Wir sind durch. Niemand will mehr mit uns reden. Nein, wir sind wirklich ein bisschen durch. Ich habe mich gefreut, wieder mal eine Woche für diese Woche mit dir gequatscht zu haben. Vielen Dank, dass du reingeschneit bist. Ich bin mal reingeschneit. Ich bin mal reingeschneit. auf Gesprächspartner. Es kommt die ganze Woche niemand ausser Florundin, kommt einmal die Woche. Du hast immer gesagt, dein Traum ist es, einen Podcast zu haben, wo du jede Woche mit jemand anderem sprichst. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ey, mach es doch so, mach doch so ein Studio und schau, wer kommt und wer sich dazusetzt und mach mit dem Podcast. Und so ist es halt eben. Das sind halt seit 385 Folgen einfach ich. Ja. Aber vielleicht kommt irgendwie hier. Ah, Mr Gibson, Mr Gibson. Willst du mehr Gibson? Nee, mehr Gibson, der hat das Büro nebenan, der kommt immer nur hier vorbei. Ich habe ihn schon gefragt. Mr Gibson. Mel. Mel. Was ist das eigentlich für ein Name, Mel?
Kurz von Melanie.
Melanie Gibson?
Ja, Melanie Gibson. Melanie Gibson.
Melanie.
Melanio. Aber jetzt im Ernst, wie heisst Mel Gibson?
Mel.
Aber heisst du irgendwie so Melandrus oder so?
Mel Gibson. Ich glaube, Mel ist einfach ein ganz normaler Vorname.
Melo?
Mel Columside Gerard Gibson. A.O. Wow. A.O. Was heißt A.O.? All of Australia ist ein Orden, der von Isabel II. als Königin von Australien am 14. Februar mit dem Ziel der entsprechenden Würdigung von Australiens Bürger und anderen Assur. War das vor oder nach seinem Meldown? Das muss man immer gucken bei so Ferdigungen. Das war Post oder Ante Meltdown, muss immer so dabei stehen bei den Orden. Mel Columseil, niemand weiss, was das für ein Vorname sein soll, Gerard Gibson. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, Zweitnamen sind einfach so, ja, man versucht sich noch so ein bisschen Klasse zu geben, aber weiss, dass es eigentlich keine Rolle spielt.
So, du kannst noch so ein bisschen Pomp dem Kind mitgeben, aber du weisst, dass es eigentlich irrelevant ist. Das ist genau wie Brad Easton Ellis, ist auch so fucking, ist schon so, bam, du wirst, you will go places mit so einem zweiten Namen einfach. Übrigens ein neues Buch rausgebracht, da bin ich gerade fertig mit Fallmega in Loch.
Wenn man halt 700 fucking Seiten liest
und dann neue Freunde kennengelernt hat,
gut, da ist es nicht so
alle recht unsympathische
Characters, aber so trotzdem, man
gewöhnt sich an die Stimmung, an die Leute,
ist auch so ein Vibey-Roman,
sehr stimmungsorientiert.
Jetzt habe ich die nicht mehr, jetzt habe ich die verloren. Zack, werden die die wieder weggenommen. Mensch, das tut mir leid. Aber du findest bestimmt noch andere Bücher in der Welt, die dich reinden. Ja, wahrscheinlich gibt es noch ein anderes Buch. Zum Beispiel die Bibel. Okay, da findest du ganz viele Freunde, die dich begleiten und dann eines Tages plötzlich gesteinigt werden. Das reisst dich manchmal ein bisschen raus aus der Story, wenn du sagst, Mensch, dieser Jeremias, der war doch geil gesteinigt, schön vom Turm geworfen. Tja, aber das Geile ist dabei, wenn du dich in der Bibel verlierst, da gibt es ein riesen Support-System um dich herum, um weiter dich in der Welt zu umgeben. Du meinst, das Christentum ist eigentlich nur eine Gruppe von Leuten, die sich versucht zu unterstützen die nach der bibel in loch gefallen was ist eigentlich das ende der bibel was der letzte komm wir schreiben noch ein ganzes buch gemeinsam zweites test der drittes testament und weißt du was du bist einfach jetzt papst okay sozusagen der der dieses ganze franchise weiter trägt in die welt wir bauen riesen Gebäude, die so aussehen wie die Dinge in der Bibel. Aber da bauen wir einen Code ein, oder? Bibelcode. Oder? Nee, oder nicht? Was ist der Raum, was sagt der Raum? Doch, schon. Ja, schon. Schon, schon. Bibelcode. Auf irgendeine versunkene Truhe oder so. Nee, lass uns so ein, wie wir so im Zahlenschloss, so eins nach oben. Genau, so eins. Wir verschieben alle Buchstaben eins nach rechts. Weil wer will sich jetzt so ernsthaft einen Code ausdenken? Ja, wer will das? Niemand. Will das niemand. Und dann machen wir irgendwo in Venedig so eine Metalltaube, die zeigt dahin, wo der Eingang ist zum Loch. Ja, oder einfach nach Norden. Einfach nach Norden. Schwierig. Nächste Woche wieder? Auf Wein und Oplaten? Auf Wein und Oplaten, du, würde ich sagen. Die waren früher auch mal geiler, glaube ich, oder? Oplaten? Oplaten waren nie richtig geil, glaube ich. War immer schon so maximal Billo. Ja? Wir müssen denen was geben, wir können denen nicht nichts geben. Ich meine, es muss ja... Die gucken zwei Stunden zu. Es muss ja irgendwann mal einen Papst gegeben haben, der sagt, dieses köstliche, frisch gebackene Fladenbrot, das wir bei jeder Messe ausgeben. Lass uns das doch mal durch so 40 Cent für 100 Stück Kuchenplatten ersetzen, die nach nichts schmecken. Nur Mehl und Wasser. Nur Mehl und Wasser. Ja, genau. Wie wär's denn damit? Ja, megageile Idee. Ja, ich bin ja unfehlbar übrigens. Das merkt man, wie die Idee sitzt. Das ist nett. Aber ich meine auch, also, per Definition. Komplett unfehlbar? Ja. Also es bringt jetzt auch nichts, mit Ihnen zu diskutieren oder so? Nee, gar nicht. Ah, okay. Ja, dann machen wir kleine, nach nicht schmeckende Mehl-Wasser-Gemische und geben den den Leuten. Und das Hauptzeichen unserer Kirche ist ja das Kreuz. Ja. Mach die Oblaten mal kreisförmig. Einfach nur damit die mal hier oben, mach die mal kreisförmig. Gut, ja. Okay? Ja. Und mach da nicht irgendwie dann so ein Kreuz reingebacken oder so. Gar kein Kreuz.
Null.
Wo du denkst, oh, was kriegen wir heute zu essen?
Kreuzbrot?
Nein.
Kreisrundes Pappplättchen.
Pappe, ja.
Pappplättchen, ja?
Okay?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Aber den Wein können wir weiterhin alle trinken?
Ja, nee, nee, nee, den kriege ich. Was ist Messwein, wirklich? Ist das ein guter Wein? Machen die eine gute Flasche Wein auf? Ist das ein schöner Greno oder ein Malianier oder sowas? Aber das finde ich wirklich eine spannende Frage. Wenn ein dann doch irgendwo ein Pfarrer zuhören sollte, macht ihr da einen richtig geilen Vintage-Wein auf, so Chateau-Petrus, oder macht ihr Quatsch auf, macht ihr so einen Tetra-Pak, so einen Lidl-Tetra-Pak auf, weil es ist auch ein In- und Schluck und dann wird der Rest weggekippt, finde ich wirklich immer spannend. Ach so. Trinkt er wirklich nur vorne der Pfarrer Priester. Ist ja wirklich, vielleicht ist da einfach Traubensaft drin, oder einfach so ein Energydrink oder irgendwieas. So eine moderne Kirche oder so. Ja, so Red Bull Himbeere oder sowas. Naja, das finde ich mir spannend finden. Wir werden es erst erfahren, wenn Stefan die nächste Phase hat und Priester werden möchte. Ich bin gespannt, wann das losgeht. Aktuell sind wir noch in der Fischzone. Nee, nee. Okay, alles klar. Dieses und mehr werden wir wahrscheinlich nächste Woche wieder erfahren, wenn es wieder weitergeht. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank an Käthe für dieses fantastische Intro. Wir wünschen euch ganz viel Glück in dieser Woche und dann sehen wir uns einfach nächstes Mal.